Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, my Game of Thrones
Season 4 countdown continues.
Last week in my Dead Character montage I asked
you to pick which video I’d do next and
overwhelmingly you all wanted to talk about
Winds of Winter.
I’ve also got some new information about
Season 4 episode titles so I’ll do that
first.
If you’re finding me for the first time,
each week I’m going to be doing special
Game of Thrones videos counting down to the
season 4 premiere.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
I always post links to my playlists so you
can see the other videos I’ve done already.
Feel free to suggest new ones.
So the first thing, Season 4 Episode titles.
Episode 1 is called Two Swords, Episode 2
is called The Lion and The Lion and The Rose,
Episode 3 is called Breaker of Chains and
Episode 4 is called Oathkeeper.
What do all of those mean in terms of the
story, here’s where things might get a little
spoilery.
So just turn the volume down for a sec if
you don’t want to know anything.
The episode 1 title Two Swords is a reference
to the melting down of Ned Stark’s two-handed
valyrian greatsword Ice into two smaller blades.
We saw an image of this in the trailer.
One of the blades is named Widow’s Wail
and is given to Joffrey as a wedding present
and the other larger blade is named Oathkeeper
and is given the Jaime until he gives it to
Brienne.
The Episode 2 title The Lion and The Rose
is all purple wedding.
I won’t mention the crazy spoiler here,
but the wedding ceremony and the wedding reception
will take up the entire episode.
This will be one of the first major events
of the season.
If you didn’t see it, the showrunners said
that there would be multiple Red Wedding level
climaxes this season, not just one.
So Episode 2 will be the first one.
I am planning on doing a couple videos just
for The Purple Wedding, because it’s going
to be awesome.
The Episode 3 title is Breaker of Chains.
Every title has multiple meanings but the
first that come to mind here are one, Tyrion’s
Chains after the last episode and two Daenerys
trying to break the slaves chains in Mereen.
So one person is getting thrown in chains
and another group is coming out of chains.
If you remember in the trailer we saw Tyrion
marching to his tribunal in chains and we
also saw Dany and her men at the beginning
of a battle.
The breaking of those slaves chains could
come in a different episode from this battle
though.
After she moves into this giant pyramid, also
from the trailer.
It’s also possible that breaker of chains
could imply that some Maester chain’s could
be broken, but this seems like it will be
mostly a Dany Tyrion Episode.
The Episode 4 title Oathkeeper is all about
the sword from Episode 1.
But it’s name also kind of informs Brienne’s
quest to find Sansa who they think has been
kidnapped.
There have actually been some behind the scenes
pics from these scenes.
Look at Podrick smoking.
I wonder where you buy cigarettes in Oldtown.
You can turn the volume back up, spoilers
over.
Now let’s talk Winds of Winter.
They’ve actually released bits of chapters
and George RR Martin reads from it sometimes
at public events.
The new excerpts they’ve posted on his blog
is an Arianne Martell POV chapter and a single
paragraph from a separate Tyrion Chapter.
It’s totally free to read, so check it out.
The Tyrion paragraph has some potential spoilers
in it if you haven’t read Dance With Dragons,
so I won’t read it here.
But I will post it on twitter and tumblr.
You can find links to my social in the description.
Here’s the full list of people with POV
Chapters in Winds of Winter.
Arianne Martell, which you can read now.
Theon Greyjoy which you can also read right
now, Sansa Stark, Arya Stark, Victarion Greyjoy,
Barristan Selmy, he actually read from his
chapters at an event last year and lastly
Tyrion Lannister.
So again I’ll post links to both those Preview
chapters on Twitter and Tumblr.
I’ve changed my comment settings so that
if you write the word spoiler it will hold
the comment so only I can see it.
So if you want to talk about spoilers in the
comments, just add the word spoiler to your
comment and it will hide it from everyone
else until I make it visible.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the rest of
my season 4 countdown videos and send me your
suggestions for which video to do next.
Right now click here for more countdown videos
and click here to catch up on Walking Dead.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!